I think the biggest problem in paracriting is that people can
get so confident that they think they can always fly in all kind
of conditions and start to push the limits.
And then at some point, yeah, there is a limit.
And then it gets, yeah, really nasty.
For you as an industry insider, how have you seen the artificial
neural networks come around and offer their assistance?
How does it work? So what will happen is that
everything will be more optimized, we will know better
and even a 3D printers that could print your whole canopy.
It works like you have two layers of fabric and the machine
can cut out all the panels and then in between those fabrics
they are welding tapes. So instead of having real ribs,
you just have tapes. You won't have the normal
billowed shape in between the cells anymore.
It will look more like 1 solid wing.
That's exciting. But the technology is there
already, It's just a matter of time.
Theoretically, how fast can our wings go, On paper at least?
I think the restrictions are mainly how much load can the
wing hold before it starts to explode the faster you go.
What is up everyone? Welcome back to another episode
of Paragliding Atlas Podcast. I'm your host, Aninder Singh,
and as you might have noticed, we are coming to you a little
bit out of schedule. And the reason for this tiny bit
of delay is that I've been relentlessly travelling across
various countries chasing air times, mostly in the Baltics,
and Needless to say, life has been an absolute blessing while
doing so. Earlier this month I had just
finished my travels in Macedonia, where I was staying
for the PwC Macedonian Edition 2025.
Although I was not racing, but just by being there at the time
of the World Cup, I got to connect with so many amazing
pilots and of course, I managed to get hold of loads of amazing
names. A couple of them you've already
heard, but stay tuned for the remaining ones that are coming
to you week after week in the near future.
And until then, here is an episode with one of the most
interesting brains in our industry.
To put it in more simple words, his main job is to design kites
for the big ships out there to help them with energy
efficiency. But guess what?
As a side gig, he started a hobby project that took off and
eventually made him create a brand that we all know today,
which goes by the name of Dune Rider.
So without further. ADO.
This is Brian van Ostheim, the brain behind taking Parakites to
a whole next level and unlocking the performance dynamics of dune
riding that we never even knew existed.
So. Let's dive right in, and I hope
you like it. Brian Van Ostheim, what an
absolute honor to have you on Paragliding Atlas.
Sir, welcome to the show. Thank you to have me here.
Brian, I want to start with Dune Rider because it's revolutionary
product which has promised the audiences, all the pilots out
there to increase the fun factor in the paragraph industry.
So what is Dune Rider all about and what makes it different from
the other paragraphs that are available out there?
Yeah, we do, Rider. We started basically just as me
and a few friends, we are all pilots and we mainly fly in the
Netherlands. So we have like really small
dunes. And we were thinking about how
can we have more fun on those small dunes and we realized that
we need more glides, we wanted more dive and more pop, so more
energy retention and we wanted to have more role that then were
the basics for us. And with that, we could, yeah,
basically increase the fun factor.
So we basically have a parakite now.
Yeah, with quite some high performance and it's checking
all the boxes from the things I just said.
I'm very curious about the trim speed of parakites because
paragliders of course, when we start pushing the bar, we start
seeing an acceleration in the ground speed and the trim speed
is not that big of a variation. But when we look at parakites,
they just seem to go a whole lot faster.
So what is the trim speed that parakites have?
And is Dune Rider a lot more faster than the other parakites
that are on the market by other brands?
So it's not a lot faster than the other brands.
It's mainly that that we can achieve a better glide and also
a worse glide. So I think main difference with
between a normal paraglider and a parakite is that with a
parakite, we want to have the best glide when we are at trim.
So with our hands down and we want to have the worst glide
when we have our hands up because then we start to dive.
So our trim speed is a little bit higher compared to a normal
paraglider. And this is also because we are
yeah, using different profiles and we are basically having a
better glide when we fly a little bit faster.
So we can, we can also fly relatively slow, especially on
the really big paraglides. But you almost don't do that.
You will feel that wait, once you start to fly a paraglide,
you will always fly it above trim speed because it's just
more fun and it stores more energy.
And from that point you can be way more playful, which are
glider. But yeah.
So we can also fly around like 30 or 80 kilometers an hour on
the dunes. And coming from a turn, it's
easy to to do all for 100 kilometers an hour, just on our
small dunes even. What I'm wondering is because in
paragliders, if you wanted to handle those kind of speeds, you
literally had to go to competition wings like something
like 2 liner performance or like the top of the line gliders were
able to give you those performance as pilots out there.
But with parakites, there's one product and it's just downsizing
which is allowing you to handle larger wind speeds.
What is the basic difference in layman terms?
Like for those people who haven't tried parachites out
there, what is the one thing that makes parachites different
from paragliders? Yeah.
I wouldn't say it's one thing. I would say it's two things.
But the most important thing is that we have kite risers and
this is like a pulley system with toccles as well in your
hands, but everything is connected.
So basically you have your speed system that is built inside your
risers. Once you're steering or you're
going hands off, for example, you're not only you're, you're
basically not deforming your trailing heads to steer.
It's basically changing the angle of attack of your whole
wing. And if you only do this on one
side, it's basically it makes you turn or it makes you dive,
for example. I think this is one of the
biggest changes. But another big factor is the
profile. Like we designed those wings
more like a kite. It's more like a kite than than
a paraglider because with the normal paraglider, the focus is
really more on performance and stability when you are at trim
speed. And for power kites, it's really
important to have the best possible stability even with the
with your lowest angle of tech. So we've focused a lot on that,
that that you can go full speed but still have a great
stability. Yeah, I saw this video on one of
your Instagram channels which said that if you hit brakes when
the parakite is diving forward, then there's a chance of
stalling it like or violent behaviour.
So why does that happen? Because intuitively for me, when
I fly paragliders, I've been told that every time the leading
edge dives in front of your head, you should stop it by
pulling the brakes and bringing it back to your head.
So how is this technology different from the usual
paragliders where braking is supposedly the safe thing, but
here going hands up is the safer thing?
This baffles my mind if you can talk a little bit about this.
Yeah, of course. Yeah.
So we are making use of a reflex profile and a reflex profile it
basically. Acts like a.
Spoiler I can actually show it to you out here like a small
model. So if the wing wants to shoot
forward, then on the regular para glider, it's pitching
forward like this and you have to break it so that it will not
collapse with the reflex profile, it's shooting forward,
but then the trailing ads is tilting up and it were acts like
a spoiler and it brings the wing back.
So it basically it, of course it can collapse in really heavy
turbulence, but most of the times the reflex will make sure
that the wing is. Yeah, moving back, coming back
to the natural position. Yeah, yeah.
And then the thing that that you were talking about by hitting
the brakes, once this happens, it's not really about stalling
the glider. It's mainly that it's can
completely collapse. Because if you if the wing
shoots forward and you don't let the reflex do its thing and you
brake just a little bit or just enough that you take out the
reflex, the whole wing can suddenly move forward and the
whole center of pressure is is moving to the back.
So that means that there is no pressure in the leading edge
anymore and it can just suddenly collapse.
So we basically say that either you do nothing when this happens
when the wing is shooting forward, just do nothing and the
reflex will solve it. But once you are in heavy
turbulence, I will would never advise this.
And then you have to active fly, but then do it a lot by heavy
pulling and pull much, but not a little bit because yeah, that's
that's not a good combination on most barricades where there is
some degree of reflex. So basically the reflex
activates the safety mechanism, but only up to a point.
And if you mess with that small little buffer that reflex is
supposed to solve for you, then of course you put yourself in
danger. But if you cross that buffer and
give it an input where it negates the reflex from the
profile, then it is a lot more easier to prevent the surge like
a normal paraglider. Is this correct?
Yeah, but The funny thing is this search will not not happen
that often. Actually the search will mainly
happen when you break that. Much that you take out the.
Reflex and if you don't do this, maybe the wing is just moving a
bit. But yeah, even if we come out
from a spiral and we don't make nice exit, even then the we've
tested this on the on Lake Garda and we, we came out from spiral.
And then after this, the wing is actually, it wants to shoot
forward, but then it stops because yeah, the reflex makes
it stop. So it's, it's actually really
easy to control those wings. You just have to keep in mind
that, OK, if it's really shooting forward, just pull a
lot or do nothing, but don't pull to the point where, yeah,
you only take out the reflex a little bit because then you
don't have the design shape anymore and the reflex is not
there anymore. So then it's suddenly like a
normal wing. Is like is there a way to
practice this in ground handling?
Like how do you develop the instinct for this?
Yeah, I think ground handling is a great way to practice this
like always for all kind of maneuvers, even on the ground to
the wing is less stable. So when while ground handling
because there's no not much wing loading on it.
So yeah, exactly practice this on the ground, especially in
turbulent air. If it's turbulent, just go
ground handling. And on the other hand, this also
tells you a lot on the conditions for the dunes,
especially if you should fly or not.
If you have your hands up and that the wing keeps on
collapsing, you can expect from a reflex wing that it will be
super turbulent because you need some pressure in the wing.
And even if you have a lot of reflex at at some point you your
lights are not rigid, so your wing can still come down and
towards you even while it's not collapsing.
What I'm wondering is what kind of collapses are the most common
one in parakites? Because for paragliders,
asymmetrics are something that happen pretty often and we are
told to do whatever opposite brake shift or opposite brake.
Or it's a fairly easy mechanism to try and navigate an
asymmetric like. I wouldn't say easy, but at
least like straightforward. But parakites on the other hand
do not have a lot of collapse videos out there.
And I understand that they might be being flown in laminar
conditions in a coast where there is very little possibility
to go out and collapse or face the collapses of parakite.
But what is the usual thing that goes wrong in the parakite
technology that needs pilot input to correct?
OK. So regarding the collapses,
yeah, a parka can collapse and I think this really differs from
type and model. But I can only tell you about
the dune riders. We are focusing a lot that once
it starts to collapse, we want to have this happening from the
tip. So from the side, because we
prefer that you have only a tip that's collapsing and not
directly the whole wing. Another thing is that we try to
make it really talkative. So before it it it's collapsing
the wing will tell you hey something is going wrong and you
need to start flying more active.
If you ignore this, then at some.
Point you, you feel like some pressure loss and it feels a bit
different compared to normal gliders.
You feel it more at your hips and your butt because it's also
like everything is speed. So the feedback that you get is
is different. So we've been testing this.
We didn't get any frontals in the in the production series.
We only managed to get some site wingtip collapses.
And this is in in really rough air.
Or for example, when we are soaring with the 12 in more than
30 knots and we are flying all the way to the ground where you
get all the turbulence from the waves.
And if you do, then don't do anything and you're not active
flying, then it might be that wingtip can collapse.
But even then we managed to, to keep the keep flying the wing
straight. So it's not really moving away
and it opens up quickly. But what is important, I think
discounts for every parakite on the market, is that once you
experience a collapse, don't keep your hands high.
You know, on the regular paraglider, it's good to keep
your hands high. It will start to accelerate and
it will reinflate. But basically you can compare it
that if you have your hands high on a para kite, you are pushed
full speed. So it's at a very low angle of
tech and it's way harder for the glider to open up again.
So what works really good is just to do 1 heart pull down the
wing starts to open up again and then bring your hands to to
glide position. So not directly hands up again.
Yeah. So these are things that that
that can happen. And I think what you need to
keep in mind of flying parakites is that in general you fly way
faster compared to other wings. So you have to take this into
account. Crest can be way worse because
of your speed. And I think the biggest problem
in parakiting is that people can get so confident that they think
they can always fly in all kind of conditions and start to push
the limits. And then at some point, yeah,
there is a limit and then it's get gets really nasty.
So basically you're telling me that there's a pseudo sense of
safety in for people who don't understand the amount of risk
that is generated and how quickly it is generated, whereas
in paragliders the learning curve is a lot longer, so you go
a bit more slower and it's more intuitive.
Yeah, yeah. Imagine that you're flying in
really high wind speeds and you're flying on 12th for
example. Everything happens just so much
faster. And I even got during
prototyping some collapses that I felt them coming and I started
to act on it and still was too late.
So it still had the collapse, but then the your response is is
too late and it still solves the problem.
But you will get the collapse. And if you are flying on the
bigger parakeet, it is more more gently.
Also when you fly with lower wing loading the chance of a
collapse is bigger. But if you get the collapse,
it's yeah, less intimidating, basically.
What's the learning curve like in this sport?
Because in in parallelizers, of course there are like very clear
cut levels which you can follow. Like you fly AE and A wing
straight after the school, you fly it for 5000 hours, you're
ready to go to AB wing. So there is like very defined
steps that any pilot can go out and progress on, but paragliding
seems to be a whole new fun way of chasing adrenaline.
And the definition of performance versus safety is
just downsizing. Like there's no other
homologation which gives you that kind of reference point.
So how does like how does the progress of a pilot look from
your eyes in the? Sport this is this is a really
interesting question, I think. So from what I can see, there
are two things happening. You have or yeah, maybe even
more, but you have the group of the traditional paraglider
pilots and they fly already and then they want to change to a
wing, to a para kite. And the other group are mainly,
for example, people that come from other spots like sky
diapers, kite surfers. In the Netherlands, it's mainly
kite surfers. Kite surfers, they switch from
kiting to para kiting and it's quite funny to see because the
people that already do kite surfing, they have control over
the para kites almost immediately because they are
used to the same system with the D power and things that is also
happening on the kite. But they don't have the the
feeling and the sense of flying yet.
And also not in combination with the conditions and flying with
other people around. And then the other group are the
people that are already flying paragliders.
And so they basically know how to fly.
And they, yeah, they are familiar with many situations in
the air, but they have to get used to a new system.
So for this group, it's it looks that it's sometimes harder
because all the muscle memory is already there, but it's
different. For example, once you experience
a collapse, it's not happening often, but if it would happen
and you keep the same reflex from flying with the normal
paraglider, you're doing it wrong.
It's the same with starting. If you Lance from the dune and
you keep your hands high, you will not take off because
there's no left and it because it's all you want to accelerate
And so these kind of things. But once you get used to it,
it's super simple. And then there's maybe only a
really small group that has no experience at all.
And they started on para kites. Yeah, and I think the learning
curve is different for different kind of people.
Some people they can fly in one day and order or for other
people it's a few weeks or a few months.
I would say for progressing and stepping up.
Just keep on flying where you feel comfortable with and don't
push too far. Don't go over your limits
because in this sport you cannot go.
Over your limits. So do everything as slow as
possible and try to understand what you are doing.
But from that perspective it's not really much different than
with normal paragliders I would say.
What I'm wondering is that is it honestly possible to do 2 sports
at the same time like aracliting and paragliding?
Or because they are intuitively so different that there is a
chance that your subconscious mind will not register things
when they happen too quickly and you might end up mixing up the
dangers and messing up because your brain is wired to react
differently in different scenarios.
Yeah, it's funny. Like in the in at the start of.
Parakites people were worried about this and from what I have
experienced it, it's not really a problem.
It's like you fire a completely different wing and you feel what
the wing is doing, so you also respond differently on it.
But maybe as a complete beginner you should not mix up those
things. Maybe either just start on a
normal paraglider first and then from there on progress to
parakite or just start on a parakite.
This opinion is not so favored by by many people just to start
on only a parakite, but I I think in the future it will be
like this anyway, at least for doom soaring.
I think for doom sewing you will almost not see normal
paragliders at the dunes anymore in the future.
Yeah. Now what I'm wondering is that
is it possible to be a good, good paraglider pilot and a good
parakite pilot at the same time? Or are these two very different
things where a human brain is only able to develop safety
mechanisms for one sport effectively, then for two
different sports, and then mix and match?
Because as I said, 5% brake pressure in paragliders is nice,
but 5% brake pressure in paragliding is freaking
dangerous because you're messing up with the reflex.
Yeah, I think you can be a great pilot in both, but I think there
goes like many more hours in in becoming a good pilot under a
normal paraglider. It's way more, it's way more
advanced, I would say, compared to a Parakite.
On a Parakite, everything with flying is just so easy.
And that's the thing why I told you people get so confident and
then, yeah, then you start to look for the limit and that's
where the danger starts. What happens if we take a
parachite into a thermal and if we circle it to a cloud base?
Yeah, it's totally possible. So you're telling me that it is
possible to go cross country on parachites as well?
Yeah, yeah, you could. But the question is, why would
you want to do this? It's not comfortable.
You have to keep your hands all the way down like at all all
time to have the best guy. So this is not ideal.
But flying in turbulence, parakites are relatively stable
so that the wings are super stable.
It's mainly about how are you going to respond.
There's more options because with every movement you make,
you are making you're also changing the angle of attack.
So for the brands that are having a parakite on the market,
it's really hard to tell like how safe is this wing in in a
thermal or in turbulence? Because it mainly depends on the
piloting and you don't know how people are piloting the thing.
There's too many variations, but yeah, I've done it and some team
riders have done it as well. And yeah, if you know what you
are doing, it's totally possible.
What I'm wondering is that why has nobody put a pod harness on
a para kite yet? Like why do we only see chair
harnesses? Because pod harnesses are much
more streamlined. And if we are chasing speed and
glide, which is the whole idea of of para kites where you want
extra speed and extra glide to increase the fun factor, then
why don't we see conventional pod harnesses coming except from
the pod that OK, you want to do some toe touches and stuff like
that. But let's say if you just want
proximity soaring on dunes, do you see port harnesses being a
part of the kit as well in time to come?
So in the Netherlands there there are some people using this
combination of parakite and port harness.
I think it depends on what you want to do.
When you're flying with the port harness, you may have one body
position and you have to deal with that.
If we fly without port harness, we have more options because we
straightened our legs for example, to get a better glide.
But we can also bend our body down or like our legs down and
come out of the harness really easily to get like a worst
glide. So if we combine this when
flying a para kite, we can easily get best glide Emily
when, for example, we want to go up or we bind when we want to
have the glide or when we are flying proximity.
But if we want to dive, we are coming out of the harness to
even get more dive. And this is something in that is
is way harder to do when you fly port harness.
And another thing is of course that we are flying in a lot of
wind. And from my experience when
flying with the port harness on the dunes in a lot of wind, the
chance of starting to rotate or getting twisted in the turn or
whatever, it's also way higher. So it's totally possible for but
for me personally, it's not that much more fun.
But for some people that are seeking for the best glide and
most lift, sure they are using a pot harness.
There's there's one guy from the Netherlands.
This guy is Afon and he is mainly flying modified
paragliders. So he's building his own guide
riser system and then putting them on normal gliders and using
it as a paraglide in combination with with the pot harness.
And you can see that he is getting like the most
performance from anyone else at the dunes and even being able to
sometimes doing 3 or 4 spirals down at the small dunes, which
is like a few years ago. This, I think this never
happened before. So it's indeed a great way to to
increase your performance. But it's not only about the
glide performance. It's also about how playful is
the wing, how much can you dive and stuff like that.
What ring is he experimenting on, if you don't mind talking
about it? I think he started on like
regular race kites, it was R1 I think and from there on he
started to experiment with D wings and even competition
gliders. So the 1 he is flying now mainly
I think it's an E fiq. Yeah, like a triple C glider.
Yeah. So height rises on a triple C
and that's endless performance basically.
Then because this the glider is insane and what what happens
when you put a characterizer on a paraglider?
What's the difference in behaviour?
What changes I would? Say mainly you don't have the
same stability when having your hands up, so flying at the
lowest angle of tech you always have to fly way more active.
When you put guide risers on the normal paraglider, I would say
the chance of a collapse is way greater.
And it really depends on what kind of glider you put the kite
risers on. Because yeah, if you have, I
know there are some competition gliders that are having built in
reflex. So on those wings, I think it's
easier to put kite risers and make it work.
But there are also some wings that are really bad with kite
risers and you don't have much speed range, speed range will be
less for sure. And after this, it will just
start to to collapse. It might be that your brake
pressure is way higher. So this also depends on what
kind of guy drives you're putting on the wing.
And another thing is that which is really important, but you
don't see it usually directly on the wing is the spacing of your
attestment points. So you have, for example, your
ABC spacing and the spacing in between those is really
important to keep the ratio aligned with your kite risers.
So if it deviates too much from the ideal positioning, it means
that you will deform your wing way earlier.
You will just deform it when you put your hands up or when you
put them down. Yeah, once they are moving away
from the perfect twin position. So like the thing with kite
risers is that they're a bit like longer because my curiosity
is that how does a kite rider kite riser change from the
regular risers? Because kites seem to be a lot
further away from the athlete or the body when I see a kite
harness attached to a guide, whereas a paraglider is much
shorter. Like the distance between the
the pilot and the glider or the lower surface isn't that long.
So is it just the length, the pendulum effect or is it the
material which is or as you said, the attachment points?
Like what is the major difference between flying kite
risers to a surface then a parallel rises to a surface?
Yeah, I think they're in in. So basically they look really
similar, but there are many differences.
So for example, the built construction is different.
A para height needs to be built way stronger because we will
experience higher G forces. We use different materials
often, I would say a little bit heavier, more heavy duty.
And of course, yeah, the positioning of the pilot is
indeed way different on the para kite, you are pretty close to
the canopy and with a normal kite it's often between yeah,
7017 to 21 meters, 22 meters. So that means if you would put
like your harness directly to a normal kite that it's deformed,
you get you don't get the shape of how it should be because the
line there's no line length. So that means that the normal
kite will become like super curved.
It will have a super high R shape.
So you would have to modify this first.
But of course, there's another thing which is we built a para
kite. We develop a para kite and it's
of course, we call it a para kite, but it's optimized for
flying. So we check all the situations
with flying. How is the roll house to dive?
How does it respond on the brakes?
How does it feel? I would say the feeling how of
how a wind. Yeah.
So how a wind feels is super important.
And then you do the same thing when you develop a kite, right?
But a kite is not really made for flying.
So you check all the stuff and that is mainly very important.
So in the end you end up with a totally yeah, different product.
I would say the main things that are similar is I would say the
airflow looks very similar. And then the the system with the
D power and the police is something that is, yeah, super
similar. I'm glad you mentioned the
manufacturing side of it because I was on your website a little
while ago and I saw that you are doing some pretty cool things
out there. Just quickly for the reference
of our audiences, like who are you and how do you make such
cool products because the SB-80 project that is basically
powering some world record speed handling.
So just, I'm sorry, I should have asked this at the beginning
of the show, but what has your journey been like in this
scenario and what have you been up to so far before Dune Rider
came in your life? Yeah, that's it's funny that you
asked this because the rider is basically a like a side project.
Still love? The humble brag over there that
this is just a side gig. The real thing is even cooler.
I wouldn't say it's cooler. It's something completely
different. So what I'm doing mainly in my
daily life is designing big kites.
So this starts from 25 square meters up to 400 square meters
at the moment. And you would ask what can you
do with this kind of kites? But we.
Fly as a 400. Like how strong do you need to
be to fly a 400 square meter kite man?
Do you need bodybuilders to pull the risers?
You need many. Bodybuilders.
So with that, we can pull like cargo, like big cargo ships.
And so my background is a bit in, I started at the company
where we were developing kites to, to, to generate electricity.
Yeah, with the kite and the ground station.
And then the kite was flying figures of eight, pulling out a
tether. And then with that we create,
we, we're creating electricity. And then we depowered the kite
at the Senate where it's not pulling much.
And then it's retrieving the kite again.
And this pumping cycle, yeah, makes it that you get
electricity. But what I learnt is that these
kind of kites are having a way different approach because it's
not only about the performance, but safety is a really big
thing. And the biggest thing is I would
say is production, because it's really hard to produce those
kites. There's many things that you
need to do differently. And also design wise, yeah,
you're just approaching it in a different way.
So we use stronger materials, we use construction methods that
makes the guide way stronger. Sometimes we have just one
single attestment point that needs to handle like around 400
kilos on just one single attestment point.
Yeah. And that's a lot.
And then even if we have this, we still need a whole bridle
with a lot of support. So the big guides I started on
were mainly liking looking like big kite surfing kites so they
were inflatable but the bridle was due to this high wing
loading thing looking way more like a paraglider.
So there are like many lines connecting to the canopy and.
Yeah, from this I started to gain more experience and I
worked already a lot with a factory that can do big kites.
And then I started to do, I basically quit my job and then
started my own business and starting to do these kind of
projects for multiple companies because I found like, oh, there
are now many more companies that want this and want this
technology integrated in what they are doing, but they don't
have the experience yet. And I can help them with it.
So, yeah, for example, SPSPAT is one of those customers.
They they want to break the speed sailing world record and
in instead of using a regular sale, they want to use a kite
because it's more efficient in the end.
So we developed this together and yeah, these are the kind of
things that I'm yeah, that I'm doing.
And I would say, So what I said about the production, it's way
different. It's more more advanced.
And even looking at the size, there's no space.
At the normal. Kite department to make to make
those big kites. So you have to make a
combination in the end. And this also makes it possible
for me to really go outside of the box because we need to solve
different solutions, different problems compared to what we
have in the kite surfing or paragliding industry.
And that this is what I mainly like to go outside of the box to
see what can we try and then then just go for it, then solve
this issue. Yeah, I mean.
What I'm wondering is 400 kilometre kilogram for an
attachment point. What kind of materials do you
guys use on this? Is it similar to what we have in
power lighting or is it completely a whole new industry
that we are not aware of? No, it's.
It's still very similar, but it's way thicker.
For example, I would say we we are trying to smart optimize all
the kites. So we are also using just
Dyneema materials for example, but also Dyneema fabrics and
Dyneema fabrics is not really common.
You bet in paragliders or in the kite swiping industry, it's way
strong. It's way stronger.
And coming back to the attestment points, yeah, we are
testing often all kind of different construction.
And this goes from even the smallest details like how long
should be a splice, how should it be splice and how should how
long should be the taper in how to cut the splice, because those
kind of things have so much influence on the maximum
strength of something. And this goes even together with
OK, then we then we stitch the attestment point, yeah, in the
strut for example for the kite. And how do we do this?
What kind of threat, how big is the stitch and how far is the
stitch offset from the machine? All those things together you
can use to really optimize the product.
But other than that, we are also testing a lot new kind of
materials. Yeah, this is something go on.
So this is something that we will see soon in the future.
I think new kind of materials that are way lighter, way
stronger and different production techniques.
So not stitching anymore, but also a lot of welding.
Yeah, that's what I was actually getting to that as a designer,
because most of the paraglider designer have usually worked
with paraglider, right. Like they they have been in
paraglider industry for long enough and they have invested
their time, soil and energy in this single sport itself.
But you seem to be having quite a diverse portfolio.
Like how did the switch happen? Like how did Dune rider come
into your life? What were the origins of this
brand From making 400 square meter kites to just normal
parent. This seems to be like a side gig
of project that is like baffles my mind because there are other
people who would invest their lifetimes in perfecting
something and you just went out and made something just when you
had like three time. It seems like that at least.
Yeah, so in my spare time I am flying as much as possible.
And because I am living pretty close to the shore to the dunes,
I can do dunes soaring a lot. And at first I was a team rider
at at fair. But I was looking for something
more. I had this idea already a long
time in my head to increase performance, to get more dive,
more role, etcetera within my company.
I was looking like I need to do, I want to do some more R&D, but
what can I do? Because if I put this effort in
big kite technology, I cannot do it alone.
I have to do it together with the company and the R.
And D goes really slowly. We can do maybe one or two
prototypes each month, but then testing those big guides is is
way more challenging. You cannot test like multiple
guides in one day, for example. So for me it was like, OK, it
needs to be a project that I can do by myself and it needs to go
fast because I like to iterate fast.
And that were the main requirements for myself.
And then I thought, why I'm not just putting my effort in
learning, designing parakeets because that's what I like doing
the most. And it's even an extra option
for me to get airborne even more and then on my own parakeets.
So that's how it started. I had the first sketch was
already in my computer for more than one year, but I didn't
produce it yet because I knew once I started on it I will keep
on doing it. So at some point I I ordered
just the first sample. And unfortunately it came a bit
too late and in the meantime I got like accident and I broke my
back. So for a few months I was not
being able to fly those prototypes myself, but luckily I
have quite some friends that are also flying.
So they were flying my prototypes and I learned a lot
from that because I was there every session, I was recording
them on video and I got the feedback from them.
And then after, yeah, a few months, I was finally able to
fly myself again. And then I figured out, hey,
this, I want to still change and this and that.
And for me, of course, this starting this project was way
easier because I already have the connection with the factory.
So the same factory is also producing a lot of paragliders.
So for this, I went to the paraglider department and they
were willing to help me. And I told them like, hey, this
is just a project, just AR and D project.
I don't know if we will go into serial production ever, but
please help me with those samples.
And they were really friendly and they want want to help.
And at some point we realized like, hey, this wing is really
becoming a thing. And it it's checking all the
boxes, all the things that we want.
And my friends were like, you should bring this to the market
that other people also can fly it.
So then I was just trying to figure out, OK, how do I need to
start a brand? Never, I never owned a brand
before. So this is something completely
new to me and I got like lots of consultancy from different
people that are already owning a brand and things like that.
Yeah, we've got in touch with Air to Crows for the
certification for the short test and low test other people wanted
to do to do a video. And that's basically how it
started. I was looking for team riders
because we also needed to have people in the video and and
before before we know yeah, we had to launch we launched in
January this year without knowing what to expect even for
the factory. They didn't know.
I basically told them like, OK, we we are opening the pre-orders
and this is the amount that you have to produce.
So I cannot promise you like minimum order or anything.
And they were like, no, we can let's do it this way.
And we see from there yeah. And that's.
And now we are here. We we did a few batches already
and production is now a continuous thing even.
And that's cool, man. That's Sebastian, your side gig.
Take off and spread more awesomeness in the world.
But tell me a little bit about some big design aids that you
use. Brian, if I ask you the question
that what goes on from drawing board to the actual production?
It's a pretty wide one. But what I'm wondering is that
AI is coming up pretty heavily. You have probably been in design
design departments for much before this whole like
revolutionary of Chat GPTS and everything coming around to us.
For you as an industry insider, how have you seen the artificial
neural networks come around and offer their assistance to
designers like you? How does it work behind the
scenes? You think this will play a big
role in the future of guide design?
I actually, I know this because I'm connected to some people
that are working on this, mainly working at the Technical
University in the Netherlands. And So what will happen is that
everything will be more optimised, so we will know
better what kind of Air Force to use or how should be even the 3D
shape of a kite. Everything will be more
accurate. So it will be mainly in the
future. You just need to have your
requirements and you need to know what you want.
And this tool will just help you reaching that goal.
And in the end, it will save you some prototypes, I think.
So this is something that's going on at the moment.
And I think this will be combined with our guide design
tools, for example, how it works now we have a separate software
for doing our designs. Then we take the output, or for
example, like every piece of output, we take it to different
simulations and we get the result and we have to, yeah,
basically have to guess on how to continue and how to improve
it. So you do, you iterate between
those programs all the time. And at some point you're like,
OK, this should be something that works, and then you build a
prototype. But you never know for sure
because it's really hard to simulate.
Yeah. The the whole canopy because
it's also moving, it's stretching and that's especially
in paragliders is in internal airflow.
And there are some people that that are already into this and
they are simulating this. But it's still super time
consuming. And I think in the future this
will be just like almost automated easy thing.
It will be like a tool. It will be like a super do.
You have any idea how far that day is like?
Until when does the end user, like me and the listeners out
there, are able to reap the benefits of this new revolution?
This is hard to tell. I'm also not that deep into this
part of the tools, but I guess this will be like 5 to 10 years,
something like that. It will be in combination with
everything together, something that is going on at the moment.
It's not only simulation that is improving our design tools, but
production is becoming different.
There's new options in production and materials there.
There will be different type of materials.
So all this combined, I think will make the whole industry
look different, way different in a few.
Years, 10 years ago, if we rolled back the clock, nobody
would have ever imagined that we could change or have a fusion
between heights and parameters. And about the parakites, you are
the industry insider who has seen the evolution of sports
over a period of time. Do you have any visualisation of
what could be coming in time to come?
Yeah, this is. Really cool to think about
actually. So maybe I can keep the folks a
little bit on parakites because otherwise it would be so wide.
But for parakites, I think like we will see different type of
para kites, you have to all rounders that are suitable for
everyone and basically all para kites are like that now.
And then we have only the high performance wing.
So that's only one other category.
I think there will be many more categories just like with normal
paragliding, but then optimized for para kiting and I think the
performance and everything will be pushed even more because
people are starting to fly those things more.
They are learning to fly them. In some years they are ready for
the next thing. For example, now the scraper is
for the expert pilot, but this might be different in a few
years if there is like many people that are flying already
on this level and they might be looking even for something more
extreme. Looking at myself and the
direction I would like to go, I think I would be the person that
keeps pushing the limits and trying to go outside of the box.
Something that I'm doing right now is looking into way smaller
wings, even smaller than the 12th, but we want to keep the
performance. So the challenge now is to get
super high performance small wings but still have the
stability, stuff like that. Once you can reach this, people
can to start fly smaller. You can even in lower wind
speeds, you can fly smaller wings.
It allows you to go faster and have a more dynamic wing because
it's also more playful and it moves more.
But at the moment this is not happening so much yet because
already a 12 is for many people, they think it's too small.
Once we increase performance, it also means that you can start
flying a smaller wing in lower wind speeds.
So I think this is one of the things that will happen in the
future. Materials and production will
change. We will have.
Different materials. Exciting times are coming, to
say the least. Basically.
Yeah. So if you look on what what's
going on behind the scenes, there's a lot of R&D into
developing new type of fabrics. And as I said before, the
welding techniques and even 3D printers that could print your
whole canopy. This means it works like you
have two layers of fabric and the machine can cut out all the
panels and then in between those fabrics they are welding tapes.
So instead of having real grips you just have tapes.
You won't have the normal below shape in between the cells
anymore. It will look more like 1 solid
wing. Damn, that's exciting.
That's a lot of performance again, but also.
Weight because you only need the tapes.
So you take away the human labour cost out of it, the small
suing of small parts, I think. In the end, it could be cheaper.
Indeed, it first needs to get to the stage where it can be used
in production. In the beginning it would be to
test small segments and to do prototyping.
Imagine prototyping, you have a great idea and you want to test
it in one or two days. In the night you just send this
model to this printer and it prints your whole wing.
It sounds like something. From the future, and it is, but
the technology is there already. It's just a matter of time and
investment to get there. It takes some time in
development and trial and error. Wow man blows my mind.
Consider how the wings will start looking eventually.
Are we finally looking at triple C's being upgraded?
Because I think our sport paragliders have been hitting a
stagnation point with triple C's for quite a while since the Enzo
3, with nothing but only small improvements here and there.
But the one you're telling seems to be quite a substantial 1, and
it seems like it has the potential to have a blanket
effect on every single category out there.
Yeah, I think you are referring mainly to performance when you
talk about the triple C wakes because there has been a lot of
development going on lately. What for?
Me Hensel has stayed around for years now without any other
brand challenging the status quo.
Like realistically, Nevio has gone close.
Yeah, 777 came with the gambit, but it fizzled out pretty like
quickly. It feels like it has stayed
stagnant for a while. I'm not saying that it's that
they will win over the answer three.
I think partly it's also that that the biggest amount of
pilots will just choose for the answer 3 because they know it's
a reliable wing and you can win competition with it.
But if you look at, I don't know, PGD and NYFIAC focus a lot
on the stability part. So it's not only, it's not only
the performance, but also when you push full speed that it's
stable. And this is something that is
very familiar to a parakite. Only difference is that with the
parakite we want to dive and then yeah, with the competition
wing you want to go fast. But keep your glide as well.
I don't know too much about it, but for me it doesn't feel like
it's stuck. A lot of things are going on.
You will not see the big steps because once you are getting
products more refined, at some point it's the only improvements
you take are really small steps. It could be that you almost
don't see them, but the differences are really small.
But I agree with new technologies and new production
techniques, these would be things where we can gain more
performance as well. And another thing is I think we
could get thinner lines, thinner lines that are as strong and
having. Even thinner lines, what do you
want, like a dental floss line or something?
Because I think we are cutting down on that trigger already
quite hard. Yeah.
So at the moment we cannot really cut away something there,
I would say. But smart things have been done.
Glide is normal, but you see it on the 2 liners and the two and
half liners that are getting into C&B category.
This is a great way to increase your performance because you
will have way less drag from the lines.
Maybe you will get a different type of line in the future,
which is really trim, stable and thin.
Yeah, it's just also a bit guessing to me, but this is
where I can see we can still save.
Your guess is one of the best ones out considering feel like
you've been a part of the market for quite a while in in various
diverse answers before I let you go.
Before I let you go, Brian, I've been very curious about question
that theoretically, how fast can our wings go on paper at least
or in the simulations in your case?
I've never really looked into this.
I think the restrictions are mainly how much force, how much
load can the wing hold before it starts to explode.
The faster you go, the higher the internal pressure will be
inside the wing. So that means it gets more stiff
and at some point it will be more like a fixed wing.
The other limit is of course your weight.
The more weight you put on on the glider, the faster you can
go. But.
Even if you would fly under A5 square meter, that's just a
maximum speed you will have with your boarding weight.
And I don't know the exact speed, but that's the limit.
We will not fly at hypersonic speeds of the paraglider.
Collapsible wings are like one of the most accessible forms of
aviation. Pack your aircraft in a
backpack, open it up in a place which is good to fly and then go
to the out of light. What I was wondering is that how
much fun factor can we add in the most convenient form of
aviation as well? Because that is a pretty huge
selling point. I think convenience is the thing
which actually makes people get attracted.
Yeah, it's true what you're saying.
It's just so easy to start with this sport and it's also the
cheapest way of flying, I would say.
Yeah. Now, we will stay tuned to your
oncoming inventions. And yeah, keep us updated on
bringing out this more awesomeness in the world as you
do. But yeah man, until then, I
think Dune Rider is doing its own bit for the community.
Looking forward to seeing more of Instagram reels on how you go
out and chase the fun factor in time to come.
Thanks a lot and thanks for. Having me here and.
To have this great chat with you.
It's a pleasure, Mike Vice. Hey everyone, for those of you
who have listened this far. I just wanted to drop in a note
of thanks because you guys are the ones who are actually making
the difference. It means the world to me
whenever I see audience retention rates remain high all
the way to the end. And I'd like to add on by saying
that if you have liked the content that you just consumed,
do consider liking, subscribing, and dropping in a rating
wherever possible. Because that is one way we can
let the algorithms of all of these streaming platforms know
that this episode is worthy of being pushed out to more pilots
in the community. So collectively, you and I can
make the sport a safer and a more fun place to be.
Well, on that note, thank you once again for joining me today.
And I'm really looking forward to connecting with you in the
next episode as well. Until then, I'm going to say
what I always say, and that is stay tuned.
Stay excited because this magic is just getting started.